[Musik]
eine wunderschöne nacht erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt meine lieben freunde ich darf euch
recht herzlich willkommen heißen hier
heute zur folge
99 also der vorletzten folge mannschaft
mit luca und skelette ich verschwinden
war ganz schnell hier oben auf meinem
dach beziehungsweise auf meinen baum
denn ich habe immer noch die hoffnung
dass hier eventuell ein phantom ankommt
wir haben gleich schon wieder einen
neuen tag deswegen müssen wir wirklich
daumen drücken dass er einen spot wird
und wenn ihr lieben freunde es ist
leider kein konto
[Musik]
wahrscheinlichen kondoms ist leider kein
phantom export meine lieben freunde wir
sehen da hinten da sind zahlreiche
monster wider in unserer villa das
skelett günstig eine kühle erfrischung
im pool und ich habe auch hier gerade
auf der wahrscheinlich in der teile
sehen das ein oder andere monster
geschieht
immer noch diesen treffen twitter hier
vorne deren zombie
mein gott das war richtig los
ich hoffe dass wir jetzt alle monster
besiegt haben hier unten die knochen
bringen uns auf jeden fall was deswegen
habe ich auch gerade alles glätte
getötet denn wir müssen ja immer noch
unten uns um unsere karotten kümmern wie
ihr bereits wisst sind karotten das a
und o im ende weil sie uns unfassbar
viel hunger zurückgeben können deswegen
bauen wir auch hier jetzt mal alle
karotten ab die schon fertig
ausgewachsen sind das werden wir am ende
der heutigen folge auch noch mal ganz
kurz zu tun damit beweglich so viel
hätten wie möglich mitnehmen die sache
ist allerdings dass heute schon die
vorletzte folge minecraft mit luca ist
bedeutet dass wir eine menge menge
produktiven schritt heute machen werden
ich habe euch ja vor einigen folgen
gefragt was mit diesen ganzen büchern
ihr machen soll und damit fangen wir
auch direkt mal an es gibt ein paar
bücher die bringen wir nicht zum
beispiel den 12 das brauche ich nicht
ich brauche allerdings schärfe ich
brauche ich dachte jetzt mal ganz gut
mannheims feuerwerkskörper brauche ich
denke ich nicht mehr das hat ja nicht so
richtig geklappt leider dieses aller
dinge können wir mal ganz kurz eben
hochschießen
[Musik]
eine hundehütte es unspektakulär
das stimmt du bist mein itunes sortiert
mehrfach schuss buch brauchen wir auf
jeden fall auch feder fall benötigen wir
nicht seelen läufer nicht vielfalt zwei
benötigen wir sogar wusste ich dass noch
ein zweiter buch habe und natürlich
diese sachen hiermit schärfe drei schutz
durch schutz vor allem für den bogen und
flamme jetzt will ich mich auch direkt
losgehen ich habe zwar nicht auf dem
bogen mit stärke 3 den lasse ich
allerdings hier denn ich nehme mir einen
neuen boden beziehungsweise machen wir
einen neuen boden weil eben so dass wir
denen dann damit verzaubern können und
quasi einen komplett frischen bogen
haben was ich auch noch benötigt ist
eine diamant taxi habe ich allerdings
hier schon ich benötige auch ein
bisschen mehr rüstung ich habe hier noch
diamant stiefel drin wusste ich doch die
goldenen karotten nämlich auch mal
direkt mit und ich benötige eigentlich
alles komplett neu also auch noch ein
diamant harnisch und jammern helm von
der hübschen hab ich mir mal ganz kurzem
eine diamanten mache mir erst mal einen
frischen diamant helm dann eine frische
diamant beruft platte mit sind wir ein
harnisch und eine neue hose jetzt werde
ich so ein bisschen mich an euren
kommentaren orientieren das habe ich ja
vor einigen folgen schon eingeblendet
hier noch irgendwo was drin ist sich
gebrauchen könnten da habe ich mir ja
vor einigen folgen schon einige
kommentare von euch eingeblendet und
zwar wurde mir unter anderem geschrieben
luca der diamant hanisch ist das
wichtigste rüstungsteile da muss auf
jeden fall dieses buch drauf weil da der
höchste schutz ist also schutz 4 das
kostet jetzt vier erfahrungs kosten den
können wir uns jetzt schon mal anlegen
bisschen mehr verdienen hier wegpacken
dann haben wir anstatt schutz 34 was mir
auch noch geschrieben wurde luca hat
durch schutz 4 also dieses buch hier das
muss auf den bogen denn dieses
unendlichkeit durchschuss kriegt da gar
nicht drauf
was wahrscheinlich nur verlust oder so
stärke 4 auf dem boden ist auf jeden
fall unfassbar krank und unendlichkeit
auch das heißt ich benötige nur einen
pfeil ich nehme trotzdem 61 mit weil ich
weiß dass ich du die den bogen
wahrscheinlich verlieren werde irgendwie
deswegen nämlich auch gleich noch ein
zweites buch mit feder fall ist sie mich
selbst erklären kommt natürlich auf die
diamant stiefel bedeutet einfach dass
wir ein bisschen sanfter fallen ich habe
hier noch in diamant helm haltbarkeit
zwei das bringt uns gar nichts die
verzauberung ich nehme allerdings jetzt
mal den hiermit und packe auf den
diamant helm
es bringt gar nichts was ich hier
mitnehme ich werde diesen kürbiskopf
tragen von daher können wir den
haltbarkeit zwei diamanten auf jeden
fall hier einpacken den diamant helm
nämlich trotzdem mal mit ich nehme mir
auch eine armbrust kurzen mit werdet ihr
gleich sehen wir für euch die benötige
und ich habe hier auch noch den
geschnitzten kürbissen setze mich jetzt
einfach schon mal auf den kopf bevor ich
es vergesse wir gehen ganz kurz deswegen
noch mal eben rüber ihr fragt euch
wahrscheinlich luca warum armbrust nach
doch gar keinen sinn etwas mit der
armbrust so richtig gekämpft die muss
man spannenden bogen ist echt ein
bisschen geiler sind ich auch ja
allerdings habe ich ihren mehrfach
schutz buch und das werde ich auf jeden
fall auf die an post parkieren das
bedeutet dass ich wenn ich die armbrust
spanne seht ihr schon wenn ich die jetzt
abschießen
drei pfeile auf einmal schießen
allerdings nur einen verbraucher es
funktioniert nicht dass ich drei jetzt
wieder aufsammeln die beiden bleiben
sonst hätte ich ja quasi unendlich
weiter allerdings nehme ich die armbrust
auf jeden fall auch mit und jetzt habe
ich nur noch dass schärfe drei starts
drei buch und schärfe 3 und
explosionsschutz 4 ich werde jetzt auf
jeden fall als schutz drei buch nehmen
und noch auf die diamant beim schutz
packen denn die diamant beine
beziehungsweise die hose ist das
zweitwichtigste rüstung style und das
schärfe drei buch kommt jetzt
selbstverständlich auf die angst da
wurden wir zwar geschrieben luca das
kannst du auch auf dein schwert packen
dann kannst du es kombinieren dann hast
du schärfe 4 ja aber eine axt nach
trotzdem eher schaden das sieht schon
eingeblendet 11 angriff schaden die nach
nur 85 und ich glaube wenn das schärfe
drei oder vier hat ist die axt trotzdem
noch besser deswegen lasse jetzt erstmal
auf der achse drauf und werde mich
primär darauf konzentrieren in diamant
harnisch packe ich jetzt
selbstverständlich wieder rüber in meine
kiste und ich werde auch die diamanten
hier reinpacken ihr seht schon ich habe
62 bruchsteine mit dabei die sache ist
allerdings dass ich noch deutlich mehr
benötige ich habe hier auf jeden fall
noch welche hier habe ich noch einige
und mehr nicht deswegen werde ich ganz
kurz mit meiner diamant spitzhacke
runtergehen und ein bisschen farbe neben
denn ich benötige auf jeden fall eine
menge
oh
ja panik hier
[Musik]
perfekt
ich habe ein paar mehrere cobblestone
soll hier vorne leuchte mal ganz kurz
aus ich werde mal ganz kurz die ebenso
ein bisschen cobblestone farben
so ich habe jetzt insgesamt sechseinhalb
stacks bruchsteine und habe hier einiges
abgebaut ich werde jetzt ja auch noch
mal ganz kurz fackeln sind was ich nicht
so spannend wird das ist jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen 4 an bruchstein
und allerdings habe ich mir gedacht
mensch ich werde keine perfekte ja ich
werde keine krassen items jetzt
irgendwie mitnehmen aus dem ende
deswegen dachte ich mir mensch lieber
dann noch ein bisschen baumaterialien
mitgenommen und ich kann dann nachher
mich vernünftig da an diesen türmen hoch
bauen in der nächsten folge und
dementsprechend auch in der letzten
folge es zu kranke verletzte folge
es ist nacht
das heißt wir haben
die eventuell noch eine chance darauf
im ruf mich da jetzt mal eine ahnung was
da hinten für eine spinne party abgeht
allerdings
möchte ich einfach nur dass ein phantoms
bond das wird alles
perfekt könnt euch eine kostenlose und
vater auf einem ballon offenbar einfach
mal das gleichen phantoms bauen die
sache ist allerdings dass sich jetzt die
sachen auf jeden fall erstmal verzaubert
habe ich habe mir cobblestone geholt und
was ich als nächstes noch auf meiner
liste stehen habe ist dass ich auf jeden
fall die goldenen äpfel mit dem muss ich
hab noch einen verzauberten goldenen
apfel und ich habe auch schon einige
goldene karotten und die ender perlen
müssen natürlich auch mit so dass ich
mich dort ein bisschen rum teleportieren
kann ich habe ja noch ein paar mehr
goldene karotten deswegen werde ich mir
jetzt hier beziehungsweise karotten
generell deswegen werde ich mir jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen gold club obwohl
hier die karotten rein in die mitte und
jetzt die goldproben rom so dass wir uns
dann hoffentlich so ein bisschen mehr
essen noch machen können ich bin hier
direkt dabei die nächsten goldenen
karotten zu verwandeln 24 stück 32 und
so insgesamt haben jetzt 64 goldene
karotten das ist sehr sehr sehr wild die
restlichen gold sachen die ich hier noch
habe packe ich jetzt mal wieder zurück
in unsere wertvolle kiste hier vorne
dann seht ihr auch schon dass mein
schild hier fast schon zur hälfte
kaputtgegangen ist deswegen werde ich
das jetzt einfach mal hier rein packen
ich brauche auf jeden fall
123456 eichenholz bretter und ein eisen
so dass ich mir zumindest auch noch mal
neues schild machen kann ich weiß nicht
ob man schild in minecraft verzaubern
kann allerdings werde ich das auf jeden
fall gebrauchen können ich habe
allerdings so ein bisschen den gedanken
dass ich mir die ganze zeit das tote
meer und sterblichkeit in der hand
behalten werde ich habe zwei stück davon
deswegen werde ich die beiden auf jeden
fall auch mit neben dem wasser einmal
habe ich am start der ist auch sehr
wichtig für die mlg sachen das votum der
unsterblichkeit und wasser einmal kann
ich ja auch schon mal wegpacken von
meiner liste die sache ist dass ich mir
aufgeschrieben habe dass ich eine kiste
mitnehmen möchte dann sage ich mir ich
hab da noch kästen oder
perfekt eine kiste ist auf jeden fall
mit am start die kiste nämlich mit denn
ich wollte nicht alle diese bruchsteine
mitnehmen in das ende sondern nur 46
oder so dass falls ich sterben sollte
ich respawn neben einem stronghold also
neben am end portal so dass ich mir dann
direkt aus der truhe ja einige
bruchsteine et cetera neu aufnehmen kann
da werde ich dann auch meine schönwerth
keinen pakt damit ich zumindest ein paar
sachen habe und ich werde dort auch noch
eine spitzhacke reinpacken in die kiste
die sache ist dass sich auch einige
betten mitnehmen werde denn mit betten
kann man auf jeden fall den ender
drachen auch gut schaden zufügen ich
habe zwar noch ein paar betten hinten im
winterdorf stehen allerdings hat man
kann ich hier mit dem backbone
jetzt ist unsere schwarz weißes brett
oder nee
[Musik]
ich hab auch sonst fast keine rolle mehr
ich glaube wir haben leider nur die
möglichkeit wirklich im village das dorf
da hinten paar betten abzubauen zuvor
muss sich allerdings auch noch das thema
tee mitnehmen was ich mir vor einigen
folgen gekostet habe 30 stück die kann
ich dann ganz einfach anzünden mit einem
feuerzeug was ich hier vorne ja irgendwo
drin habe da dann kann ich da mit dem
änderten auch auf jeden fall ein
bisschen schaden machen ich habe nur
angst dass ich mir damit die welt ein
bisschen kaputt springen die
ofenkartoffeln dass ich gleich hier
diese neuen stücke mich nur erstmal
jetzt auch dass ich ein bisschen was
essen kann eine schaufel brauche ich
eigentlich nicht mit diamant spitzhacke
brauche ich eigentlich auch nicht
allerdings nehme ich das ganze
sicherheits dabei wirklich einfach mal
mit so die ganzen sachen kommen da rein
hier wo von kartoffeln es sich gleich
hier in bogen mehrfach schuss habe ich
noch das einzige was ich jetzt noch
stehen habe jetzt geschnitzter kürbis
den habe ich schon auf den kopf und
frauen
denn ich möchte mir noch tränke der
stärke der regeneration der heilung und
des sanften falls machen wenn wir eine
von einem phantom finden aber ich habe
leider wirklich fast kein platz mehr
hier im inventar ich werde jetzt noch
immer ganz fix unterwegs hier
[Musik]
oder fast kein schaden gemacht
die beiden sollen sich mal boxen ein
paar sekunden später
vielleicht der letzte sonnenaufgang
gehen wir dem projekt breakfast mit luca
sehen werden
es ist so wundervoll
und am leuchtturm da hinten
ich
könnte echt
wieder anfangen zu weinen wir werden uns
jetzt auf jeden fall allerdings erst mal
wieder von dem dach hier runter bewegen
hier kurz den kopisten abbauen und jetzt
ganz fix zurücklaufen die kisten crypt
das hier nicht noch irgendwas anderes
porter ist wirklich fast nichts kaputt
gegangen ist hör mal ganz kurz wieder
aufbauen aber auch nur ein bisschen erde
führt und die hoch steinstufen dann
haben wir das auf jeden fall auch noch
mal fertig und wenn ihr dann den web
download bekommt in der nächsten episode
web das geht nicht
kleine mini ipad
[Musik]
skelett wenn ihr dem fc auch in der
nächsten episode bekommen dann solltet
ihr auf jeden fall alles laufen ich
nehme doch mal ganz kurz den knochen
hier mit und lass das verrottete
vielleicht hier so dass wir das
natürlich selbst wahrscheinlich auf
unsere karotten unten anwenden können
obwohl ich eigentlich anderthalb 6
karotten das sollte eigentlich schon
dort nicht krass ausreichen aber jetzt
hat auf jeden fall wieder ein bisschen
mehr gewachsen wir müssen uns jetzt ums
brauen kümmern von daher werde ich erst
mal
eine kiste aufstellen damit ich nicht
die sachen immer rumschleppen muss also
hier ist mal den ganzen buch
steinreichen zum braun brauche ich auf
jeden fall einiges an materialien hier
die erde wieder rein die bruchstein
stufe und jetzt benötige ich auf jeden
fall erstmal meinen etwas nicht benötigt
eine gasttrainer ich bin nötige meine
ganzen wasserflaschen hier vorne und was
ich auch noch benötige ist lohnen staub
bin habe ich hier vorne drin davon habe
ich acht stück jetzt laufen wir ganz gut
da ist ein spray attackiert mich nicht
alle tag ist jetzt hoffen wir hier rüber
zu unserem frau stand der ja hier ist
jetzt können wir hier drei
wasserflaschen reinpacken hier erstmal
ein bisschen lohnstopp damit wird das
ganze überhaupt antreiben können und
jetzt benötigen wir noch schrott pulver
stimmt gar nicht wenn wir die nutzen
ich brauch mal ganz kurz und dann sehen
wir uns wieder wenn das durch ist
[Musik]
so freuen ich habe jetzt gerade mal zu
ende gebaut und zwar habe ich drei
tränke der heilung 2 die mich quasi
direkt heilen dann habe ich zwei mal
einen trank der regeneration 2 also dass
er dass ich schneller quasi wieder meine
leben eine herzens zurück bekomme und
habe zwei stärke tränke die mich jeweils
verein minute 30 stärker machen wenn der
ändert rache dann bald war sie zurück zu
seiner pace fliegt und ich bin dann
quasi boxen kann mit meiner diamant ax
ich werde übrigens meine betten doch
nicht mitnehmen dass da habe ich einfach
nicht den platz für und ich kenne mich
selbst und ich weiß dass wenn ich diese
betten dabei habe dass ich eher mich
selbst in die luft sprengen als dass ich
da irgendwie schaden beim ender drachen
bewirke deswegen hier mal ganz kurz
wieder des rats von rhein und jetzt sind
wir glaube ich auch richtig ausgestattet
ich habe meine diamant axt und das
nochmal ganz plötzlich ein bisschen
nervös schon ne
ich habe aber glaube ich alles auf jeden
fall werde ich die sechs ofenkartoffeln
noch hier lassen sind ein bisschen
unnötig ich habe auch ein halb sechs
goldene karotte nicht ob dann kann ich
33 davon auf jeden fall hier lassen
jemand hin werde ich auch hier lassen
die ganzen trinke werde ich mal hier in
einer reihe packen so dass ich weiß dass
hier so die tränke sind den den trank
brauche ich auf gar keinen fall den
packe ich noch mal kurz hier vorne waren
die jahrein die newa benötige ich auch
nicht dann sollten wir es eigentlich
auch schon hinkriegen mit dem ganzen
anderen kram dass ich brauche jetzt
einfach mal ab und wir haben alles
eingesammelt also ich werde auf jeden
fall die ganzen kopf ist benötigen um
mich an den türmen hoch zu bauen ich
habe zwei toten der unsterblichkeit
falls sie sterben sollte dass sich die
schnell in die hand nehmen kann ich habe
pfeile mit dabei für den bogen und für
meine armbrust mit mehrfach schuss ich
habe genügend essen auf jeden fall mit
dabei ich habe die gold etliche habe
ender perlen ich habe auch tnt mit dabei
so dass ich mich mit dem inder drachen
so ein bisschen explosions schaden
anrichten kann ich habe genügend
cobblestone mit jetzt wiederhole ich
mich auch mittlerweile schon und ich
werde aber auch diese 25 werde ich hier
lassen und das ganze jetzt auch noch mal
aufgebaut hier die diamant axt an erster
stelle fackeln benötige ich da glaube
ich nicht ich wer hatte
ich nehme sie trotzdem sicherheitshalber
mit magma die armbrust auf 3d dem bogen
hier die beiden sachen benötige ich
eigentlich auch nicht ich nehme trotzdem
mit und ich glaube dass das ihr dann
auch meine ausrüstung ist
weder fall zwei schutz 34 geschnitzter
kürbis schild
[Musik]
ich habe mir eigentlich gedacht dass ich
jetzt in stronghold fahre und dass die
nächste folge dort startet allerdings
möchte ich noch mal auf nummer sicher
sicher sicher gehen
und zwar mir noch mal eure kommentare
durchlese weil ich will da nicht
verpacken am ende von daher meine lieben
freunde ich würde an der stelle die
heutige episode minecraft mit luca jetzt
auch beenden wir gehen ein letztes mal
schlafen nicht im baumhaus sondern
nostalgie mäßig in meinem haus hier oben
nochmal ein aller alle allerletztes mal
da haben wir gar kein bett mehr
wie immer doch rüber ins baumhaus meine
lieben freunde dass
ich bin nicht mit ihr kämpfen muss sich
jetzt aber
ein allerletztes mal gehen wir schlafen
meine lieben freunde ich werde ja nur
noch in der nächsten episode kurzem
einen standort markieren um einen punkt
vor dem stronghold von daher meine
lieben freunde ich würde an der stätte
die heutige episode minecraft mit luca
als auch beenden wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann das kann einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da abonniert main
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr
die letzte episode folge 100 am sonntag
um 18 uhr nicht verpassen wollte am
sonntag um 18 uhr werdet ihr außerdem
den cee'd von dieser matt bekommen ihr
werdet einen download von dieser map
bekommen und es wird neues merchandise
in den luca shop.de kommen dieser extrem
nah ist das wetter und dieser extrem
leise wo die basierend auf diesem halb
halben jahr lang minecraft projekt sechs
monate lang ging das ganze jetzt von
daher an die lieben freunde stellt euch
einen wecker sonntag 18 uhr es wird
episch es wird lang es wird krank ich
gehe schlafen und dann sehen wir uns
sonntag wieder
macht's gut
[Musik]